je n'ai jamais cherché à fréquenter que
des artistes et je préfère fréquenter
les gens de la rue
[Musique]
pas de devenir un citoyen du monde
Jean-Paul Riopel était un enfant de
Montréal c'est ici au 4089 avenue de
laurigny à Montréal qui l'a grandi un
lieu important nous dit sa fille
isotriopell était très attaché de toute
façon ça sa mère a toujours résidé dans
cette maison là après le décès de son
père et évidemment c'était
son point de ralliement
dans ce quartier ouvrier Riopelle est né
d'un père qui l’encourageait jeune à
faire de l'art et d'une mère qui ira
plus tard jusqu'à détruire certaines de
ses œuvres il a fréquenté l'école
primaire Saint-Louis de Gonzague qui
bientôt portera son nom jeune un de ses
voisins a changé sa vie nous dit Hélène
de Billy auteur d'une biographie sur
Riopelle et il est allé à l'école dans
les environs ici et surtout il s'est mis
à fréquenter son maître Henri Bisson
[Musique]
merveilleux professeur ça a été son
premier professeur de dessin et qui
habitait sur la rue Garnier pas loin ici
c'était un des moments de pur bonheur et
quand Jean-Paul a dit par la suite que
peindre était une maladie c'était
probablement référence au moment où il y
a attrapé le virus si on veut avec un
rubisson
ce virus sera contagieux car dans les
années 1940 le Montréal artistique est
en pénibilité et c'est dans l'atelier de
la ruelle Saint-Hubert que se réunissent
des automatismes et de futurs
signataires du Refus global il était là
avec Marcel Barbeau Mousseau les
danseuses Françoise c'est l'hiver
Françoise Riopel Françoise espère
instruit Opel et tous ces gens-là se
réunissaient ici c'était un peu un petit
lot de d'avant-garde dans une mer de
conformisme
[Musique]
un peu plus à l'ouest rue Laval près du
Carré Saint-Louis Jean-Paul Riopel
rencontre sa première épouse Françoise
l'espérance Riopelle qui l'accueille
dans sa famille les deux feront la paire
c'est le point de départ où
avec François vous savez un couple c'est
toujours très fort quand on s'aime et
qu'on fait des choses un peu à la marge
il faut être ensemble
après avoir reçu les enseignements de
polémique bordure à l'École du meuble
réappel quitte le Québec à la fin des
années 1940 pour la France mais une
partie de son cœur reste dans la Belle
Province je reviens peut-être bon en
1974 il se fait construire une maison à
son image à l'Estérel à l'intérieur il y
a des souvenirs de chasse un des grands
amours de sa vie nous dit Huguette
Vachon la dernière épouse du peintre il
revenait à chaque automne pour venir à
la chasse à l'oie à la chasse à
l'orignal et tout ça d'ailleurs vous
voyez les vestiges de toutes ces chasses
dans l'atelier un petit peu partout il y
a des oies des chevreuils et des
orignons
c'était c'était vraiment un amateur de
chasse et puis il y a fait ici toute la
série des icebergs donc 74 son atelier
construit mais donc les icebergs sont
autour de 76 donc Jean-Paul s'est
installé dans l'atelier en haut
dans cette maison à l'Estérel riopait la
construit un immense atelier avec des
fenêtres laissant entrer la lumière du
Nord une lumière vitale pour lui c'est
plein nord parce que Jean-Paul voulait
jamais de lumière directe de soleil
direct dans son atelier alors donc c'est
plein nord tous ces ateliers même en
France c'était il travaillait dans les
endroits où le plein nord la lumière du
printemps
le terme maison Jean-Paul on allait
toujours d'ateliers en atelier j'ai
jamais été dans une maison de Jean-Paul
le dernier atelier de Jean-Paul Riopel
sera celui de l'elosoi situé sur le
fleuve Saint-Laurent près de Montmagny
entre deux parties de chasse il réalise
en 1992 son chef-d'oeuvre l'hommage à
Rosa Luxembourg c'est aussi là qu'il a
fait au début des années 2000 ses adieux
à la création et puis un moment donné il
y a les deux demain appuyer sur la table
et puis me dit Huguette j'ai les mains
cassées
mais il y a les jamais après pouvoir
reproduire et le savez puis il savait
que c'est un adulte qui faisait à son
paysage à sa créativité à tout
leslausoi il a acheté en 1995 le manoir
MCF firstone Lemoine situé sur une autre
île l'île aux Grues encore aujourd'hui
dans ce manoir la main de Riopel est là
et si ces murs pouvaient parler ils en
auraient long à dire cette situation
parce que c'était près du fleuve parce
que ça avait toute une histoire puis
parce que c'était pas banal puis-je en
poser des problèmes
il est venu mourir sur une île au milieu
du fleuve Saint-Laurent faut le faire
un Nike qui voyage à travers le monde
[Musique]
l'âme de Jean-Paul Riopelle plane encore
sur les lotrux sur l'Esterel et sur
Montréal son corps est enterré dans la
ville où il est né au cimetière
Notre-Dame des Neiges sa fille et sa
dernière épouse sont déterminés à garder
sa mémoire bien vivante si vous restez
une année à vivre qu'est-ce que vous
feriez
j'essaierai de la prolonger ici
[Musique]